amazon's going to cover 100 of college
tuition for its hourly employees so
first step congratulations noted good
guy amazon we should give a little round
of applause very good very good very
good amazon offering to pay the total
cost of college tuition including books
and fees for its 750 000 operations
employees in the us starting in january
most people in philanthropic efforts are
like oh man i sent five kids to college
somebody like oh you know what i went
real big i sent 50 kids to college jeff
bezos andy jassy they're like we're
gonna send 750 000 people to college and
we're gonna pay for the whole thing
absolutely incredible they'll also begin
covering high school diploma programs
geds and english as a second language
certificate for employees so when we
look at this the employees are eligible
for the program they have to be working
there for 90 days or more it makes all
400 000 employees who joined dern during
the pandemic eligible to access this
education they brought on 500k employees
in 2020 and they are offering now
sign-on bonuses for new employees worth
up to 3k in some areas of the country so
when you start to think through this you
say okay well what exactly is going on
here and college should be a really good
thing but it's college degrees in a way
that will teach you what i would
consider more traditional information
most colleges are not going to teach you
about personal finance they're not going
to teach you about inflation they're not
going to teach you about how the real
world works they're not going to teach
you how to markets work they're going to
teach you how to invest so even though
that amazon should be drastically
celebrated for something like this it
still doesn't replace the need for you
at home for us and for everyone else in
the country to get educated about
personal finance we've got two quotes
here with first from dave clark the ceo
of worldwide consumer at amazon he said
this new investment builds on years of
experience supporting employees and
growing their careers including some
unique initiatives like building more
than 110 on-site classrooms for our
employees and amazon fulfillment centers
across 37 states today over 50 000
amazon employees around the world have
already participated in career choice
and we've seen firsthand how it can
transform their lives
next up is brian alzaski i believe is
how you say that he's a cfo of amazon he
said we're spending a lot of money on
signing and initiatives and while we
have very good staffing levels it's not
without a cost it's a very competitive
labor market out there
i gotta say
amazon gets a lot of heat
they hired 500 000 people last year
during a pandemic when the unemployment
rate in america went over 10 percent
you know who who saved america amazon
saved america last year that's what
happened is they were hiring hundreds of
thousands of people and now they're
saying we have 750 000 operations
employees in the u.s and we're going to
pay for them to go to college yeah but
it's in the context when you look at
like that yes but if you look in the
context of their hourly uh employee
turnover rate is a like 150 percent a
year
okay so if you work there for 90 days
you can get free education
that's what they're basically saying is
i think the cfo is basically saying that
uh the labor market's very tight how do
you convince people to go there they'll
pay cash bonuses they already pay at
least 15 an hour right how many
companies have an internally stated 15
an hour minimum wage right not a lot
amazon trying to do the right thing uh
on top of that they now are saying by
the way another perk will give you is if
you work here for 90 days we'll pay for
your education and so i think that what
they're what you're watching is free
market forces at work right remember the
national
minimum wage is what 7.25 still it's
been that way since 2008 2009 yeah for
more than a decade the government hasn't
changed their minimum wage but the free
market eighty percent of american
workers already make more than fifteen
dollars an hour why because competition
breeds the best market conditions and so
when you look at it they're saying okay
we've got to pay a minimum wage that's
actually good for our employees second
is we may have to pay bonuses we have to
do all this stuff we have to educate our
employees at the at the job we have to
get them skilled all these type of stuff
now we're also going to pay for college
education we're going to pay for geds
we're going to pay for all this other
stuff
it's a big business i get it this shit's
expensive though like we i don't think
that they get enough credit for trying
to do the right thing by their employees
because everyone always looks at like oh
but like they can't go to the bathroom
or whatever like sure i am positive that
there are so you could find negative
things they employ over a million people
somebody somewhere had a bad experience
but
to look at 500 000 people being hired
during a pandemic and then have these
types of benefits most other companies
don't offer these types of benefits you
can't get your college paid for you
don't get uh 15 an hour and so i think
that we just have to remember there are
definitely some bad situations and
everyone likes to harp on that but there
are a lot of positives and this company
specifically has changed a lot of
people's lives yeah so there's a couple
things with this right 500 000 500 000
jobs during the pandemic i don't think
people realize how much that is i just
looked it up quickly that's more
people they employed during the pandemic
than the total number of employees in
montana rhode island delaware south
dakota north dakota alaska vermont and
wyoming
[Laughter]
they employed more people than states
multiple states combined multiples
that they hired oh there's just those
individuals individual states okay so
they hired more people in one year than
those states you just named each have
employed currently yes total
incredible are they going to be the
world's largest employer within the next
who who's the largest right now is right
now
i just looked it up the first i saw the
u.s department of defense
no walmart is the world's largest
private our august public
corporation corporation how many do they
have 2.3 million people and amazon is at
what right now amazon's at like a
million it's like 1.2 1.3 yeah so so
walmart has just under two times as many
people as well and their business is
growing i would assume i don't know the
percentage but much faster well they
announced that they're going to hire
another 750 000 people yeah you know
you're a boss
they'll be there by the end of the year
you know you're a boss when you just
make announcements like
today we're gonna say we're gonna hire
i don't know 500 000 people and then you
actually go and do it right like this
isn't just like oh empty promises like
they literally go and hire 500 000. well
there's there's a bunch of nuance to
this obviously right like you have to
look at uh people don't stay that often
right their turnover rate is super high
so when they're announcing new hiring
jobs percentages people aren't gonna
stay they're gonna have to hire more
people and so forth and they all these
projections are based off of that but
then also when it comes to free
education uh
you have to look at you know there's
there's fine print and all this stuff
right so you get awarded a certain
amount it's used at certain educational
institutions whatever those are examples
i don't know what amazon's policy says
uh we can look it up but it but also
it begs the question of like why doesn't
amazon just open their own school online
school i saw someone mention in the chat
like whether it's a
like an accredited institution that
other people can attend or whether it's
just kind of an accredited online
institution that people within their
workforce can take classes at and they
go hire the teachers and they make it uh
more economic sense for themselves like
i wouldn't be surprised if they did
something like that when you're talking
about someone who has the potential to
employ more than 2 or 2 million people
globally you might as well start
offering benefits that are more cost
efficient to you and build out something
that can scale up quickly as you add 750
000 more jobs this year maybe a million
next year maybe another million after
that right so you can quickly see how
these benefits get super super super
expensive for them and they've done a
bunch of analysis on this right like i'm
not an idiot they obviously built out
models and they did all these things to
understand kind of the cost for this but
also you would expect that uh they want
to build a program that can scale up
over time and as they continue to add
more employees be more cost efficient so
i wouldn't be surprised if this is kind
of like that first step into offering a
more holistic solution that eventually
includes much more people than just you
know however many thousands of employees
are currently being offered this hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.compomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help
[Music]